aiutiamo le persone a vivere il viaggio
come un momento di crescita e
ispirazione di terapia per l'anima per
farlo
le mettiamo in connessione con chi possa
essere d'aiuto in questo cammino alla
ricerca della felicità vorrei che vi
concentrasse su queste due parole
felicità e connessione uno dei mali del
nostro tempo e che continuiamo a
cercarle all'esterno la felicità nel
vestito nuovo
nell'ultimo modello di iphone nel cane
nei gatti che sembrano essere gli unici
a capirci nei figli che crediamo debbano
essere una nostra emanazione cerchiamo
di sentirci più vicini agli altri
attraverso un iper connessione che può
rischiare però di renderci più
frammentati
continuiamo insomma a riproporre la
mentalità
se avessi sarei ma così facendo non
otterremo altro che l'antitesi della
felicità rimanendo solo più soli e vuoti
e occorre quindi ribaltare completamente
il paradigma e per farlo noi crediamo
che la chiave sia avere delle relazioni
sociali positive a guardarci anche
attraverso gli occhi degli altri può
aiutarci in questo percorso alla ricerca
della felicità non è un caso che appunto
ricerca della felicità alla mano e la
qualità delle nostre relazioni sociali
risulti essere proprio un fattore
predominante nel determinarla
quindi io le persone con cui lavoro ci
siamo appunti chiesti quali potesse
essere questa chiave per creare
connessioni positive tra le persone
affinché si potesse trasformare il
sempre più diffuso senso di solitudine
infelicità
la risposta che ci siamo dati è viaggio
il gadget fatti da sempre
lo strumento più potente che abbiamo a
nostra disposizione per entrare in
connessione con gli altri però negli
ultimi anni ha sempre preso più le forme
dell'intrattenimento e meno della
formazione e questo ha fatto sì che ci
concentrassimo più sulla meta e non sul
perché profondo che ci spingeva a
partire quindi occorre nuovamente
cambiare paradigma e destinazione umaga
si inserisce proprio in questo contesto
ribaltando completamente la concezione
del viaggio infatti a chi sta per
partire non chiediamo tanto dove vuole
andare bensì chi desidera conoscere
siamo infatti il primo e unico tour
operator al mondo che propone viaggi
ispirazionale selezionando e raccontando
realtà turistiche sconosciute ai più ma
interessanti per chi vede il viaggio
come incontro raccontiamo insomma storie
di persone che vale la pena conoscere e
che possano essere le risposte per le
domande che il viaggiatore si sta
ponendo perché è vero che non troveremo
mai le risposte al nostro esterno se non
aspiriamo con le domande giuste quindi
navigando in internet nei principali
portali di viaggio che conosciamo tutti
ci imbattiamo nelle solite domande
quando volete partire
dove volete andare con quale mezzo
volete spostarvi su destinazione umana
troverete tutto un altro genere di
domande
quindi chi volete conoscere appunto
perché state partendo qual è il perché
profondo che vi sta spingendo a partire
che tipo di ispirazione state cercando
ma anche che esperienza volete vivere
nella struttura che andrete a scegliere
le nostre strutture appunto quindi le
destinazioni umane non sono raccontate
non sono divise per area geografica o
almeno non solo
ma sono divise appunto per ispirazioni
le ispirazioni che abbiamo scelto sono
44 sulla base di quello che secondo noi
il viaggiatore di oggi sta cercando e
cosa cerca soprattutto cerca cambiamento
possono essere scelte di vita radicali
quindi proprio il classico mollo tutto e
cambio vita ma anche semplicemente una
strada nuova
cerca ruralità quindi immersione nella
natura siamo ormai abituati a vivere
tutti in contesti urbani anche molto
inquinate abbiamo bisogno di erin
immergersi nella nella moralità magari
anche di sporcarci le mani nella terra
cerca innovazione sia un'idea innovativa
imprenditoriale per la mente magari
cerca un viaggio dove possa conoscere
qualcuno che lo aiuti a svilupparla e
cerca spiritualità come vi dicevo
all'inizio siamo confusi spesso ci
sentiamo soli e frastornati e ci
sentiamo anche un po perche abbiamo
bisogno di ritrovarci magari di farlo
con qualcuno che possa guidarci in
questo percorso
insomma nelle nostre destinazioni umane
che sono in tutta italia dalle langhe a
pantelleria troverete non solo delle
ispirazioni e quindi persone che vi
ispirano ma potrete vivere delle vere e
proprie esperienze immersive in cui
mettervi alla prova
vi racconto qualche esempio
appunto sul cambiamento il classico
mollo tutto cambio vita aprendo
agriturismo ma è stata davvero pane per
i nostri denti ad esempio da paola
dell'agriturismo ca del buco potrete
vivere per qualche giorno come un host e
capire se questo vostro sogno è
realizzabile o è semplicemente un utopia
e poi abbiamo andrea e federica qua
gioco in caso il podere san giuliano di
bologna loro metteranno mettono a
disposizione dei dei viaggiatori che li
vanno a trovare la loro esperienza ormai
decennale nella realizzazione di una
delle aziende agrituristiche più
innovative d'italia quindi ho un'azienda
agricola magari tradizionale voglio
innovarla voglio confrontarmi con
qualcuno che puo aiutarmi in questo dà
loro posso farlo
e infine gli adorabili andrea patrizia
di del sasso elminia bed and breakfast
sulle colline della val marecchia
il loro motto è facciamo l'amore con la
natura quindi da loro potrete ad esempio
semplicemente fare semplice in realtà
non lo è
riprovare il tempo di vivere magari
facendo una camminata sulle sulle loro
colline o anche immergendovi nella loro
vasca riscaldata legna sotto le stelle
della della valmarecchia
insomma è chiaro che siamo nell'era del
turismo esperienziale non siamo gli
unici a dirlo anche tripadvisor
attraverso questa ricerca del 2014 tre
barometer ce lo conferma nel 71 per
cento degli intervistati dichiara
infatti di voler partire per allargare i
propri orizzonti il 62 per cento perché
alla ricerca di un senso di libertà
il 47 per cento per un arricchimento
culturale e sempre il 47 per cento
perché vuole migliorare i propri
rapporti sociali
il viaggio sta quindi tornando ad essere
ad assumere nuovamente il suo senso più
tradizionale cioè le persone partono
perché cercano non soltanto una meta non
soltanto un luogo ma anche una crescita
che sia sia personale che professionale
l'innovazione sta nell'interpretare
questo bisogno proponendogli e quello
che è davvero un nuovo viaggio di
formazione
non voglio però che intendiate il
viaggio di formazione come un qualcosa
di noioso che prescinda
dall'intrattenimento e dalla parte
emozionale non è così
il punto è che siamo individui felici
solo nel momento in cui ci sentiamo ha
realizzati in tutte le sfere della
nostra vita che sono il lavoro svago e
la famiglia
serve quindi coerenza tra queste tra
sfere altrimenti rischieremo una corsa
frenetica per rubare del tempo all'una
piuttosto che all'altra senza in realtà
a trovare mai tempo per nulla
l'individuo se ci pensate che è davvero
che a chiederlo aggiunge di avere il
successo non è necessariamente solo
colui che sa l'individuo che è successo
è colui che mette in coscienza che
quindi affianca alla conoscenza
l'esperienza è per questo che su
destinazioni umano non proponiamo solo
delle idee che potrebbero apparire anche
effimere ma mettiamo il viaggiatore alla
prova attraverso delle vere e proprie
esperienze che gli consentano di
radicare quello è che ha imparato
durante quel viaggio
l'individuo che è successo è quindi una
persona che sa essere qui ed ora che
riesce ad essere un tutt'uno con quello
che sta facendo solo se riusciremo a
fare questo costruiremo davvero una
nuova era felice è un nuovo futuro
è per questo che diciamo che
destinazione umana non è un qualcosa di
esterno a noi destinazione umana siamo
tutti noi è il nostro interrogarsi è il
nostro metterci in discussione è il
nostro essere affamati di idee e una
giornata come oggi lo dimostra
destinazione umana e quindi il nuovo
viaggio che parte dall uomo e arriva
all'uomo perché crediamo che la vera
felicità non sia realizzabile mai
completamente da soli parte da una
nostra ricerca individuale passa
attraverso connessioni positive con gli
altri per tornare nuovamente a noi è
solamente più evoluti
d'altronde il viaggio è la metafora
della vita e la vita stessa il più
grande viaggio quindi non limitiamoci ad
attraversarle indossando tante maschere
diverse ma viviamo la pieno avendo il
coraggio e l'innovazione di essere
semplicemente noi stessi quindi vi
auguro buon viaggio a tutti